and we spoke on the red carpet recently
you told me your brother's a huge comic
book fan so what was his reaction when
he found that you were on a taro I I
think the the first first of all when
you found out I didn't tell I actually
didn't tell anybody because everyone you
know my family a lot of my family washed
you know Teen Wolf in my nephews do and
they were devastated because they you
know but my brother found out from a
comic book website the one he wasn't a
specific one every day I'm not quite
sure that's called and uh found out that
I was gonna be playing the role and he I
thought something's wrong with I thought
something I thought my nephew was hurt I
thought something was going on he was
like hysterical and what is going on and
he's like you're you're playing Roy
Harper he's literally like the Robin to
the Batman of the series and I was like
I didn't really know a lot about it what
I went into it didn't I didn't um it
came out of nowhere it was a one meeting
and then they gave me the role and I was
like okay now I know I look like the
character so now I have to figure a lot
more about the character and um the
thing that stuck with me was the fact
that I this is this will be the first
time where because I'm always playing
that the bad guy or things like that and
you know I am a little rough around the
edges kind of bad boy asked on the show
but he's able to have a really big
redeeming quality and then kind of you
know save save a lot of people in aid to
you know people's lives so I was that's
the one thing that stuck with me I was
really excited about that
se not being a kind of comic book geek
was not anything you thought he's oh god
what was the strangest thing he told you
about the whole world he'll is that true
can that be right
well he he told me that the fans you
know obviously he's it's fine I feel
like I'm being interviewed everyday by
him which is so funny because he I'm
like I've told you everything that I
know you know I might have to have him
sign like an indie ace okay no
disclosure so he cannot so we cannot
tell people what's happening but he just
said you know the fans are so invested
and you know you're gonna see a lot of
that and which I have seen a lot of that
the most unexpected people that I
wouldn't think you know I mean I thought
it was maybe a more teenage show but
it's not as a chart demo our demos a lot
higher so and now you know I have like
you know like so many different types of
people coming up to me you know saying
that they really enjoy the comics and
that's great and so I'm just
excited be a part of it so the things
that you've told you about the comics in
green arrow what would you really love
to say happen in the show at any point I
would love mm-hmm
you know it's interested because with
with it with Emily's character she plays
Felicity Smoak of course she she blew
everybody away from the beginning and
that's why they made her a series
regular in the first place
and I it'd be interesting because their
chemistry her not and stiver Oliver's
chemistry is pretty electric it's really
from right from the get-go psych you
know she's fawning after him all the
time and he's flirting with her and
everyone's wanting I think they call it
all olicity to work out the shippers are
saying all this city yeah that'd be nice
to see but at the same time you know if
they get together it's gonna ruin the
whole you know so that would be fun to
see it's some sort of thing like that or
to see felicity Smoak's character get a
romantic romantic involvement maybe Roy
will meet you know Felicity you never
know I doubt it because I guess I'm
right now they only team mean Thea are
the only teenage you know people on the
show and I knew Felicity months it might
be like 25 so technically they'd be
robbing the cradle
so Allah seemed like right yeah that
would be really interesting but a few
seasons of it yeah I actually don't even
think I'm 18 yet so technically be
illegal so Felicity cannot you know go
after Roy's so that's probably never met
a novena and plus do would probably be
to rob so any advice the advice I give
to Roy is like I hope you a washer
hoodie it work you know hopefully a
washes your honey for you be I would guy
would tell him I don't mean just to
start trusting people I think you know
let people in a bit I know they know
he's lived a long life of love not
letting again and he has a reason to do
that but at the same time you know these
people are I think they're genuinely
cares about Roy and uh and I think you
know I know he teaching me who cares
about her but right now it's looking
like Roy will do anything anything in
his in his you know anything possible
to unmask of hood and to become a part
of Oliver's team and I do think that you
know possibly doing something to to harm
Thea could could come about by him
trying to do that so I don't know we'll
see
he's a session is uh you know the Roy
Harper's like the kind of becoming a
fanboy of Oliver Queen but you really
you don't know if it's because he really
wants to work with them or because he
wants to uh you know possibly betray him
oh yeah that's all arrows hidden agendas
it's the best should be like a little
little extra with my hip hop good dog
with my hip hop dancing yes we would
love to say it's horrible it looks like
a Beckham NSYNC video this is what my
choreography looks like my stunt
choreography it's funny I saw I don't
think they're gonna release it which is
unfortunate I'm actually glad they're
not gonna release it because it's
embarrassing they put together a season
one blooper reel and just kindly you
know would we didn't know about it they
sent it to all of us and you know you're
laughing laughing until your parts come
up and they like they're adding sight
and sound effects and making you look
even more like a loser than you already
are so you know I hope that doesn't come
out but you know season two I'm sure I'm
gonna be clumsy and fall and you know
that's that's always how it is so you
know you just you just live with it
know if you can see any characters from
those DC comics that you brothers told
you about come into on a season two or
future seasons any point who would you
like to see it be interesting I keep I
keep saying Black Widow and it's not
Black Widow it's it's Lance's Laurel
Lance's kept her character is supposed
to be this this pivotal character that
you know could really come in and toss
things up and my brother keeps asking me
he keeps asking me you know this is this
who it is it is and maybe I should even
see that also there's really you know
there's me some new characters I'm sure
if you guys have read their if they're
going to be joining and some very very
well-known characters that have been in
you know prior movies so
and it's gonna be exciting to see they
cast as those people and you know or if
they can get it get some of the people
from the actual movie so they played so
how come Oh No yeah you never know
anyways looking pulled out they just
wanted to come in um it's funny because
I it's the one it's the ones that I say
are always the ones that people start
speculating so this is not you know I
obviously don't know I know that there
are a lot of popular ones but it'd be
nice to see passion it'll be nice to see
obviously it almost Superman or you know
things like that to come in but I don't
know if that will happen but uh I don't
know maybe maybe flash or like Green
Lantern maybe you know we're not two
greens yeah you know if I'm sure I mean
Ryan Reynolds sees you know it's not
like he's a big movie star or anything
that's so much downtime you know we'd
love that on the show we people might
have to audition though so yeah this is
the thing no one's gonna be like you
never know so you know I mean if Ryan is
available and he's watching this
interview right now time for quick
additions you know he's probably
following me on Twitter and you can
watch this you sure it take together
well just call Blake we'll get her to
talk to Ryan yeah no obviously you
saying before that you pick up several
months after that really memorable
season finale for season one oh yes
quite something wasn't it yeah yeah how
is that gonna work do you think for the
show for fans like coming back in and
and what was it like filming on that
finale on that old watchman says well it
I didn't realize I had seen watch him
before and you know it was a big grand
to kind of you know the production and
it was actually I'm gonna enjoy the
movie but I didn't realize that we were
going to have almost the same treatment
as they did it's they they've they
allotted so much time for us to shoot
the finale and we had such a great team
doing it that everything was preset when
we walked in and they were there were
been five sets on five sets already pre
set up with other cameras
you know we had cranes we had you know
cameras attached to cars and it was just
this it actually was really epic when we
were doing it wasn't just done in post
it was actually they made it feel like
the destruction was actually going down
which was amazing
and I was actually like trying to
everybody's always funny because I'm
always it takes me a while to I always
have the bad luck where I'm running into
hit my mark and I was run into like one
of the extras running by or something so
that took a while cuz that happened and
that would probably make the glue as
well but uh but um it was just the way
it turned out I didn't actually I saw a
few scenes from the finale I've not
watched it all the way through because I
I'm very upset with what happened when
at the end with the Tomas character but
um I choose just incredible so I uh I
know that by reading it it was
incredible I haven't seen the final
product but I hear that it was just as
good
you